[Music]
whether you're a student who's
struggling to stay afloat in a difficult
philosophy class or a working
professional who wants to build new
knowledge and hone additional skills or
a lifelong learner
who would like to develop a customized
learning plan for yourself
I've got tutorial services for you
I'm Greg Sadler and I love philosophy
not just teaching it and talking about
it but helping learners progress in this
field that I'm so passionate about my
students have included people from all
walks of life from CEOs medical
professionals to regular undergraduate
students who want to make it through a
class and finish their semester well
here's why you should look tutorial
sessions with me not only do I have 20
years of experience successfully
teaching learners from all different
backgrounds I also have a talent for
taking difficult philosophical texts and
thinkers topics concepts distinctions
and presenting them in a way that people
from all walks of life can relate to and
learn from I'm also very happy to work
with you one-on-one at whatever pace you
want to approach the material I work for
you I help you out if you'd like to see
my rates or to book me for a tutorial
sessions or just to find out more you
can click the link below in the video
description
that will take you to the reason il
website check out my tutorial sessions
if your goal is to really improve in
philosophy you want to book the best
somebody who has a proven track record
of helping learners progress
[Music]